when it comes to comic book movies fans
have an insatiable appetite for scraps
of news about what might happen to their
favorite superheroes and considering
these super Cemetery we got at the end
of Avengers infinity war it's probably
no big surprise that Marvel movie
fanatics are even hungrier for news
about the highly anticipated follow-up
that's why we're spinning up the rumor
mill once more to see what the Russo
brothers have in store for Avengers for
want to avoid finding out what might
happen in the next Avengers movie and
the whole MCU spoiler alert then you
shouldn't have clicked on this video you
big dummy the death of Tony Stark one
redditor claiming to have connections
with quote a reliable source has
reportedly been told that Spider Man far
from home will open with Peter Parker
mourning the loss of his mentor Tony
Stark according to the reddit post the
movie's plot will revolve around stolen
stark technology that Spidey has to
retrieve whether the reddit post is the
real deal or not it wouldn't be much of
a surprise to protect Tony Stark's
demise as Marvel fans all know Robert
Downey jr. is contract with Marvel
Studios is finished after Avengers 4 so
the longest-serving member of the MCU
may go out in a blaze of glory as a
result can you think of a better way to
retire from being a superhero than
biting the dust to save the world
didn't think so sorry didn't mean to say
dust Pepper Potts suits up ever since
Pepper Potts briefly donned Iron Man's
rescue armor and Iron Man 3 fans have
been dying to see her suit up and join
the action again she came to starts aid
during the attack on his Malibu mansion
proving herself more than able to slip
into some armor and help out given that
half of everyone Tony knows has suddenly
disintegrated Stark is going to need all
the help he can get as he attempts to
undo what Thanos has done
so will pepper potts be among the new
recruits
Gweneth Paltrow Instagram suggests she
will be in a 2017 post that the actress
has since made private Paltrow share to
potentially spoilery picture of herself
getting a foot massage on set which also
revealed she was clearly wearing a
motion capture suit on her legs she
didn't turn up at any kind of CGI get up
in infinity war so the only logical
explanation is that she was filming
scenes for Avengers 4 at the time the
actress all but confirmed this was the
case during her 2018 appearance on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert when you
were working on the movie did you thrust
your hand towards someone wearing like a
blue suit with ping-pong balls glowed on
blue yes
his nebula the main villain nebula
played by Karen Gillan has been on the
periphery of events so far but the
daughter of Thanos could turn out to be
a crucial player in Avengers 4 with her
arc potentially coming full circle she
started out hating her adopted sister
Gamora but they reconciled before Gamora
was killed by their so-called father an
infinity war the 3rd Avengers outing
borrowed heavily from 1991's Infinity
Gauntlet comic book series and nebula
plays a huge part in its conclusion in
the sixth issue story nebula is captured
by Thanos and sadistically tortured a
moment we've already seen play out on
screen and infinity war she's the one
who is eventually able to turn the
tables on Thanos stealing the gauntlet
from him the problem is nebula is so
messed up at this point that she ends up
being even worse than that oh s--- with
the gauntlet forcing the intergalactic
warlord to team up with the Avengers in
a bid to stop her Gillan has dropped
hints in the past about the film's
potentially staying true to the source
material she explained in the 2017
interview with Screen Rant
when I was preparing to play nebula the
first time I read the Infinity Gauntlet
I loved it because it was like the most
Nebula heavy comic she added that it
would be amazing if the movies were to
follow the same arc and said I don't
know yet very big secret but I'm hoping
Shuri steps up what Conda made a valiant
attempt to halt Thanos his invasion of
Earth and infinity war but the fictional
African nation sustained devastating
losses in the process and
was before the mad Titan even used the
Infinity Gauntlet King T'Challa was one
of the unlucky souls turned to dust when
Thanos snapped his fingers leaving
Wakanda without a leader going into
Avengers for the stage seemed set for
two challahs younger sister Shuri played
by Leticia right to accept the Black
Panther mantle and rally her people for
round two with Thanos this exact thing
has happened in the comics and Reginald
Hudlin
2009 black panther series T'Challa falls
into a coma after a battle in Shuri
takes over as the hero of Wakanda
it's a premise that could certainly
unfold in the planned black panther
sequel or Avengers 4 Wright herself has
expressed an interest in following
Hudlin story she told Screen Rant in
2018 if the opportunity came about then
why not it would be comic-book accurate
yeah that would be amazing it means more
training more learning and it would
really be an amazing adventure I'm
excited
recently revealed concept art from the
first Black Panther movie confirms early
designs for sharees black panther outfit
already exist so it's starting to look
like a matter of wind she'll become the
new black panther not if Loki fakes his
death again back in Thor the dark world
we saw Loki faked his death and plenty
of Marvel fans think that was just a
preview of him pulling it off again an
infinity war despite Thanos saying who
Rose erections this time in fact leaked
set photos seemed to confirm that Tom
Hiddleston will indeed return as Loki
for Avengers 4 in some capacity though
whether these images reveal a flashback
or some kind of time-travel mechanics is
anybody's guess Red Skull and the
Infinity stones not many people expected
to see Red Skull pop up in infinity war
but it turns out the Nazi sympathizing
villain could have closer ties to the MC
use overarching plot than we realized
real name Johann Schmidt the former
Hydra boss was the main antagonist in
2011's Captain America the First Avenger
but he vanished at the end of that movie
after touching the tesseract with his
hands his whereabouts became a mystery
but we know exactly where he ended up
when Thanos arrives on vermeer in search
of the soul stone an infinity war he
discovers that Red Skull has become the
stones guardian
thud the stones I even held one in my
hand but it's cussed me out banished me
here
Thanos acquires the soul stone by
sacrificing the person he loves most
Gamora now that he has it is Red Skull
free to go about its business according
to the Russo brothers he is and his hunt
for the Infinity stones might not be
over as part of Voodoo's infinity war
viewing party the Russo brothers took
questions from fans
one of whom asked about red skulls
future they explained red skull is free
to leave for mere and he is also free to
pursue his desire for an infinity stone
so good he still have a part to play in
Avengers for Avengers end game in June
2018 fans noticed that cinematographer
Trent o palak had added the fourth
Avengers movie to the credit section of
his personal website casually dropping
what appears to be the title of the
movie in the process o palak who worked
with the Russo brothers on Captain
America the Winter Soldier Captain
America Civil War and Avengers infinity
war listed the upcoming Marvel tent pole
as Avengers endgame a title that might
have just been foreshadowed on a few
other occasions a post on the
independent points out that the phrase
endgame has popped up in a few Marvel
movies before now for example there was
Tony Stark's angry monologue and age of
Ultron with Avengers we can bust arms to
us all the live long day but that up
there that's that's the end game
then there was dr. strange talking to
Tony after he gives Thanos the time
stone and infinity war why did you do
[Music]
we're in the endgame Oh palak has since
deleted the end game part of the title
and now has the movie listed simply as
Avengers 4 but let this be a lesson to
all you aspiring cinematographers if
you're working on one of the biggest
movies in the world
maybe check with your bosses before you
update your online resume
[Music]